a tournament is taking place tomorrow to  honor our fallen heroes and their  families  patriot golf day is an 18 hole event  with all the proceeds going to the folds  of honor foundation  the nonprofit organization helps spouses  and children of either disabled or  fallen service members  organizers say they're thrilled to hold  an event like this locally  on memorial day i got drawn to this  because the  founder of the organization was a was a  fighter pilot from oklahoma he's kind of  my same age group  it resonated with me on what he was able  to start  and i was able to take some of his ideas  and he gave me a lot of help with it  and get this event kind of off the  ground  everything starts tomorrow morning at 7  30 at angel park golf course that's near  rampart and summerlin parkway  it's too late to sign up to play but if  you'd like to donate to the cause  we have more information on our website